Speaker 1: OK, before the break, I talk to
you about the conspiracy theory with new life,
essentially, which it's not and it's not.
It's gone from I guess I would say some people
have really bad side effects to the vaccine.
Do we know for sure that the vaccine hasn't
killed anyone?
They've now gone to the vaccines for covid
have killed thousands of people, tens of thousands
of people or even hundreds of thousands of
people.
That's the new conspiracy.
Now, Tucker Carlson, Fox News propagandist,
is a guy who's been I wouldn't even really
call it playing coy.
The only aspect of it that's coy is that Tucker
is almost certainly vaccinated and works at
Fox News, which has stricter vaccination guidelines
than Joe Biden proposed two weeks ago to the
United States.
Remember Joe Biden's plan?
His directive is if you've got more than 100
employees, everybody either has to be vaccinated
or has to test weekly.
OK, FOX policy is you've got to be vaccinated
and submit your vaccination information or
you've got to test daily and you've got to
wear masks at Fox News facility.
So while on air, Tucker and others are attacking
the Biden plan on vaccination requirements,
FOX, they work for Fox, which has a stricter
plan.
So, OK, Tucker, he's almost certainly been
vaccinated.
He was probably first in line as soon as he
could get it, maybe even got it early.
All right.
So Tucker has gone now from repeating.
I don't even know that I want to use the word
milder, but repeating somewhat milder conspiracies
about vaccines to now repeating the debunked
claim that thousands might be dying from vaccinations.
A Media Matters has the coverage and says
during the September 20 broadcast of Tucker
tonight, Tucker railed against the vaccine
requirement for active duty service members,
lying that thousands could have died, that
thousands have died from the vaccine.
In a segment that included claims that the
vaccination requirements are a ploy to weed
out and expel, quote, sincere Christians in
the ranks, the free thinkers, the men with
high testosterone levels and anyone else who
does not love Joe Biden.
And accusations that the U.S. military runs
PR for Satanism.
Carlson claimed that a presentation given
to members of the Army, quote, falsely claims
that only three people have died from the
vaccine.
Carleson then told viewers that reports collected
by the Biden administration itself indicate
the number is actually in the thousands.
I mean, explain that in a moment.
Let's listen.
Very dangerous propaganda,
Speaker 3: white supremacy in the military
is a crisis, said the most unscrupulous people
in Washington.
But that's not what it was about.
What you just saw on tape was, in fact, a
power grab.
The message.
No one who does not support our political
party is allowed to bear arms.
That's what they're saying very clearly.
And because it's the Democratic Party doing
the talking here.
There was also, needless to say, vicious racial
angle, too, because there always is.
Right.
Congressman Steve Cohen of Tennessee, explain.
Speaker 4: The guard is 90 some odd percent,
I believe, male, only about 20 percent of
white males voted for Biden.
You got to figure that in the Guard, which
is predominantly more conservative.
And I see that on my social media and we know
it.
They're probably not more than twenty five
percent of the people that are there protecting
us who voted for Biden.
The other seventy five percent are in the
class.
That would be the large class of folks might
want to do something.
Speaker 3: So if you're white, you're dangerous,
says a sitting member of Congress, that clip
was from January.
Of course, that was the same month that Lloyd
Austin announced he was cracking down on this
extremism that a few months, late
Speaker 1: January was the same month as something
else, too.
I just don't remember what else happened in
January.
Speaker 3: After reading from the same song
sheet, Mark Milley told the US Congress he
was working to root out white rage in the
military.
OK, and yet, after all of this, because we're
keeping score as of today, we're not aware
of a single white supremacist on active duty
who has been discovered by the Pentagon and
fired, not one.
So that threat didn't exist, interestingly.
Speaker 1: Would we even know if that's the
case?
I mean, are our discharge proceedings typically
made public?
I mean, it's not clear.
It's a question at minimum at all.
Speaker 3: It was fake.
That was all a lie.
Several National Guard troops were relieved
of duty around the inauguration that no one
has ever explained why they were fired.
Then a senior commander in the Space Force,
Lieutenant Colonel Matthew Lohmeyer, lost
his job.
And we know why his crime was criticizing
Marxism.
That's a firing offense.
Now, then in August, Lloyd Austin came up
with a new political purity test.
This one was specifically designed to separate
the obedient from the free.
Can't have any of the latter category.
Austin said he planned to fire anyone in the
entire armed services who would not submit
to the covid-19 vaccination shot.
Speaker 1: So, Tucker, now building to the
case that there should be no mandatory vaccination
in the military and then going on to say some
really, really wacky things here.
Let's continue.
Speaker 3: That would get the Democratic Party
nothing.
The point of mandatory vaccination is to identify
the sincere Christians in the ranks, the free
thinkers, the men with high testosterone levels,
and anyone else who does not love Joe Biden
and make them leave immediately.
It's a takeover of the US military.
Here's how they're doing it.
This show is just obtained, a PowerPoint that
the army is using to justify mandatory vaccines
to the troops.
This is an actual slide from an on your screen.
You will notice there the sympathetic portrayal
of Satanism.
How many children were sacrificed to Satan
because the vaccine, the slide reads apparently
sarcastically.
Then the presentation proceeds to list the
so-called tenets of Satanism, which are taken
straight from the Temple of Satanism website.
So here you have the United States Army doing
PR for Satanism.
The rest of the presentation is less shocking
that, but it's utterly shoddy and dishonest.
For example, it falsely claims that only three
people have died from taking the covid vaccine.
Reports collected by the Biden administration
itself indicate that number is actually in
the thousands.
Speaker 1: OK, so that is not true in the
end, even remotely the sense that Tucker Carlson
is saying it, the false reporting on the Veirs
system, which anybody can submit, is then
called Biden administration data that's being
collected.
The website just exists.
It was there under Trump and it was there.
It continues to be there under Joe Biden.
And then the false or at least unchecked reporting
of side effects and death surveyors is used
to say stuff like what Tucker just said, now,
I'm not going to pull it.
I don't want to encourage anyone to submit
a false report.
But you can go and look at the VA system and
start the process of submitting a report.
Don't do it.
I did it up until the point at which I would
have submitted it and I started typing in
David Pakman, you know, sir David Pakman died
from the vaccine treated by this doctor.
You know, whatever.
You can just submit it.
Anybody can submit the information.
And it's being taken as, quote, proof by the
anti vaccine to say that all of these people
are dying.
They take it as gospel evidence because it's
a government website, but they're ignoring
the fact that it's not verified.
Anybody can show up and report anything.
And then it's part of the reporting.
It doesn't mean that these are verified, vetted
or confirmed instances of vaccine issues,
problems or whatever the case may be.
There's no validation required there.
Now, I think it's worth mentioning, even if
it were true that thousands died from the
vaccine.
Now, like, I hesitate to even do this because
it's such a can of worms.
But if it's true that Thout let's call it
three thousand, imagine 3000 people died from
the vaccine.
Not true.
But just imagine you're still way more likely
to die of covid as a healthy person than of
the vaccine.
I'm not saying it would be OK if thousands
of people died from the vaccine, but if thousands
of people died from the vaccine out of the
hundred and eighty two million fully vaccinated
people, that would mean you have a zero point
zero zero one six chance of dying from the
vaccine.
That's 500 times smaller than your chance
of dying from the virus.
If it were true, we would have to really think
about that.
But it's not true.
Importantly, it's not true.
So it's Tucker, again, being extremely irresponsible
about vaccines.
And then also recently, just just to kind
of just show you the full circle on how irresponsible
he's being.
He also said Brazilian president gyroball
scenario doesn't need to be vaccinated because
he had covid.
This is not true.
But this is Tucker claiming it put them in
place.
Speaker 3: Not some restaurant is just following
them his orders.
So de Blasio just issued a warning to Brazil's
president, Charbel S.R.O..
He topass Bulstrode not to come to the UN
General Assembly because he's not vaccinated.
Speaker 5: Yeah, we need to send a message
to all the world leaders, including most notably
both senario from Brazil, that if you intend
to come here, you need to be vaccinated.
If you don't want to be vaccinated, don't
bother coming because everyone should be safe
together.
Speaker 3: Really, because folks already recovered
from covid, so he doesn't need the vaccine,
no one who's recovered from covid needs the
vaccine, they have greater immunity than people
who get the vaccine.
This is insane.
Speaker 1: That is not true.
That is a lie.
What's insane is that Tucker is repeating
these things.
We now have multiple studies which show you
are more likely to be reinfected if you've
had covid and don't get the vaccine, then
if you do get the vaccine, OK, it is not true
what Tucker is saying.
What is apparently true is that if you're
vaccinated and recovered from covid, you have
stronger immunity than if you were merely
vaccinated alone.
It's not a reason to go out and try to get
covid, but there are studies which say recovery
plus vaccination is better than vaccination
alone.
A lot of caveats depends on timing.
Did you recover from one of the earlier strains
or did you recover from a later?
There's all these different caveats, but what
Tucker is saying is absolutely wrong.
And this gets us to the next story, which
is that of the Brazilian unvaccinated president.